well 50 years ago today astronauts were
launched to the moon for the last time
in NASA's Apollo 17 Mission but why
haven't we gone back by joining me is
the man who knows everything about the
university astrophysicist author of the
new book Starry Messenger Cosmic
perspectives on civilization the great
Neil deGrasse Tyson rejoins me Neil and
what a wonderful waistcoat if I may
start with that
okay thank you thank you I don't want to
show off for anything but now look why
have we not gone across the plan we call
it a vest
why have we not gone back to the Moon in
50 years
I have my own reasons for thinking so
I'm happy to share them with you
when we first went to the moon we have
to remind ourselves why
all right we've there's been a lot of
cleansing of the memory of the
motivators of what motivated us to do it
in the first place it was in response it
was reactive
to the Soviet Union they beat us in
practically every space metric that
mattered over that time they had the
first satellite the first mammal which
was Leica the dog uh the first human
they had the first woman the first
dark-skinned person it was a a black
Cuban remember Cuba was of course part
of the Soviet Empire or
friends with them and so they they had
so many firsts
that we didn't that we said all right
how are we going to what are we going to
do let's go to the moon and so by the
time we got to the moon and realized
Russia actually isn't headed there it
took some of the steam out of sort of
the militaristic motivations that got us
there in the first place allow me to
remind you that this Apollo 17 was the
first mission to the Moon to have a
scientist on it and by the way it was
the last mission to the Moon right so we
tell ourselves we're explorers
discoverers and it was really about
flexing muscle on a geopolitical well
now there's a kind of there's a kind of
counter it's not a kind of counter
narrative to that exploring aspect
because I I remember when I was a kid
watching these Rockets go from Cape
Canaveral and feeling so enthralled that
the world used to watch these things and
now it seems like we've gone backwards a
bit like air travel air travel on
Concord used to be London and New York
in two hours 58 minutes now it takes
twice as long I don't understand how we
going back quids in these things Prince
William though Prince William criticized
space tourism and travel he said this
the idea this space race is on at the
moment we've seen everyone trying to get
Space tourism going it's the idea that
we we need some of the world's greatest
brains and Minds fixed on trying to
repair this planet not trying to find
the next place to go and live
what do you make of that Neil you know
the argument that we've got climate
change we've got real pressing problems
here therefore we should suspend all
exploration off the planet until we save
this one
yeah I don't I don't like bad-mouthing
Royals but if you allow me a moment to
do so let's go back 30 000 years let's
go back 30 000 years we're all living in
a cave and you have the cave Elders the
wise Elders in the back and then you
have some young whippersnapper youngans
who who they peer out the cave door this
cave door has hinges apparently in my
example but they've moved the Rock and
they look out and they see mountains and
and valleys and streams and and trees
with fruit on them and they go to the
cave elders and say we'd like to go
explore and the cave older say no we
have cave problems that we have to solve
first in the cave before you exit the
cave and see what else is out there
that's what people sound like to me when
they say we have problems on Earth let's
solve them first before we go outside of
the earth without recognizing that by
the way uh your smartphone can find
Grandma's house in traffic because of a
system of satellites launched into space
you have full active video tracking of
hurricanes and storms and tsunamis okay
from images taken from space so to say
space is something other than what you
should care about just move back to the
cave because that's kind of where you
belong how important is somebody like
Elon Musk with SpaceX particularly with
the the satellites of course which you
know have been used for example in
Ukraine to help them in this war against
Russia what do you think of musk and
what he's doing in this area
yeah so musk um I think it one of the
biggest contributions he's making is
he's trying to drive down the cost of
access to space that's sort of a a a a a
a slightly buried objective here buried
not that anyone's purposefully burying
it they're just not noticing that this
is an important driver because if you
can draw if you can take down the cost
then other kinds of activities can then
unfold in space such as space tourism by
the way we let's think about it we I
don't know the future I don't have a
crystal ball but I can imagine a future
where space tourism is routine it
becomes commoditized and everybody you
save up a few vacation uh paychecks and
that'll get you into space you know
people will line up and want to do that
and there's nothing like seeing Earth
from space it is not the color-coded
countries that were drawn on your school
room Globe you see Earth as nature had
intended you to see with oceans and
lands and clouds that can change you
just by being a tourist in space so no I
don't I'm not with the people who are
saying don't do that let's stick to
Earth yeah
and if you use that kind of logic you
never do anything because there's always
something more important that stops you
doing something fun
um you made some predictions on American
television very recently about what
would happen by 2050. two of them I
thought were quite likely self-driving
electric vehicles yep I think we're
gonna get that pretty well are
um a visiting alien to Earth yeah I
think that's highly likely by 2050. but
the second one or the third one on this
list humans will have the ability to
regenerate their limbs that was a real
little eye popper for me are we gonna
really better do that okay well
I want so I so let me let me put that in
context that appears in the books
chapter called exploration and Discovery
and I go through 150 years of the
exponential growth of Discovery and the
role that Science and Technology plays
in shaping civilizations and practically
everybody predicting at the beginning of
each 30-year period got it wrong yeah
that you can make linear predictions and
maybe some of that work but what
typically happens is a discovery comes
in from the side from above From Below
why limbs
lived okay I'll tell you why so again
I'm not I'm not I so I gave my
predictions so that in 2050 people could
laugh at how wrong they were
that's why I gave the predictions so I
said let me just try it so white limbs
because we you and I are approximately
the same age we learned biology in an
era where we said the Tree of Life
humans are at the top and we are the
most the Pinnacle of evolution I
remember hearing biologists say that and
teachers teach that excuse me it was
white man were at the top of the
evolution that depending on which
textbook you use but and I think to
myself suppose this is what a cosmic
perspective does to you suppose some
other animal made that same chart if
newts made that chart they would say
we're at the top because we can
regenerate Limbs and they would pity
humans on The evolutionary scale because
we can't all right
we're at the top I get it three
seconds I'm just saying because
regenerating limbs exists in the Genome
of other animals and we're all related
genetically okay all animals on earth
have common DNA so Grant take a snip of
that nip tuck it in US bada bing line up
the veterans first I'm gonna get you
back on in 2015. to see if you're right
about this but Neil we've run out of
time I can talk to you all night thank
you you're always fantastic